[Music]  before the wave of sexual harassment  allegations news broke in Hollywood  Taylor Swift stood before a judge in  court and testified about being sexually  assaulted by a man during a meet and  greet in 2013 I am here to give you  permission to be angry this time named T  Swift one of the silence breakers in  this year's Person of the Year issue pop  star opened up for the first time since  her August groping trial telling the mag  what powered her uncensored testimony  Taylor says her mom became physically  ill after her cross-examination that she  didn't make it to court quote I was  angry in that moment I decided to forego  any courtroom formalities and just  answer the questions the way it happened  she added why should I be polite I'm  told it was the most amount of times the  word has ever been said in Colorado  federal court Taylor then shared advice  for other victims quote do not blame  yourself and do not accept the blame  others will try to place on you  [Music]